jeff a lot of filmmakers complain about
getting
well for lack of a better word i guess
screwed by distributors
with hidden costs and different things
can you talk about how this happens
and what filmmakers should look out for
yeah that's it's it's very real
i mean a lot of filmmakers the right
word is screwed
um it's they all of a sudden
um you get a statement and you owe them
money
because they've spent so much money on
marketing and this kind of stuff and you
think like where did that
go so listen a lot of it's real i spoke
about marketing and how important it is
and you should tuck away a lot of money
to market
so the distributor is marketing for you
hopefully they're spending lots of money
on your behalf to market your film to
get it out there you want them to do
that
um the only problem is sometimes they
will spend in areas that benefit
them and not you i'll give you a great
example okay
film markets so they attend most
distributors attend you know at least
five or six major film markets a year
and it's expensive really like i don't
know if you've ever been to canada or
berlin or
it's you go there hotel rooms are
fortunate especially jack them up during
those festivals and you know those
markets
um they have to fly you know and they
fly first class sometimes and and they
eat fancy meals and
entertain a lot of people with expensive
bottles of wine and this kind of thing
now that's good because hopefully
they're making sales
but if they're not making sales that
cost is coming right back to you
and you're paying for that and they they
disseminate that cost
through all the films that they
represent and now the thing is
you know a lot of them charge a flat fee
for markets plus
so it's general market attendance fee
plus direct expenses related so here
would be so let's say you get charged i
don't know ten thousand dollars for them
on your film gets charged ten thousand
dollars for them to attend can
but then they take somebody out for
dinner and and basically talk about your
film
supposedly only your film um and that
dinner costs you know six hundred
dollars that comes
you get charged back um if they talked
about
five films hopefully all of them got but
sometimes they charge the full six
hundred dollars to all five films
that's that's this when people talk
about getting screwed
they don't even know how badly they're
getting screwed like that's stuff that's
not even auditable you can never
you what are you going to relive that
dinner you're going to say hey
like they don't even tabulate it that
way it's not like they say oh here's a
dinner and can
between this person and this person and
him which it's not like a lawyer who
gives you a log
right they say can you know market
expense
and um ancillary expenses for your film
only in another
4 500 you say what was that well we had
to
entertain people we had to do this you
never know and you never know if they
charged every single film that
so chances are they're making more money
off of that than they are
off of selling your films that's the
screwing that people talk about
and it's very real it happens a lot on a
regular basis
because it's so easy to do it's so easy
to get away with it
it's almost unauditable that's the trust
factor
so how do you prevent it you put a cap
on your expenses
you say to the in the contract you say
um
you you can't spend more than you know
say five percent of
the revenue that you're generating
unless you get sign off from me
so if you want to do an additional
expense say and run an ad
you know do another market do this that
then i have to sign off
and give approval and distributors don't
like that because they don't like to
be accountable and sign off but that's
how you prevent it it's one of the only
ways to prevent it
and it's it's a pretty common thing to
do i do i mean it's
i wouldn't do a distribution deal
without that because expenses can run
wild
but it's not in the boiler plate that
they get no of course not so okay so
it's in the boiler plate that i give i
remember i have the boiler
i have the i have in my files the the
independent producer boilerplate
contract that they should use for
distribution and the distributors have
the
distributor boilerplate contract that
they would use and there's some
major differences sure all that all the
terms are the same but the way
they're skewed you know mine tend to
skew more
favor of the producer right and then you
come to
but that's that's the classic screwing
and there's
there's another classics there's there's
two other ones actually oh please
second one is reporting of revenues
like how would you ever know if a deal
got done
that didn't get reported let's say they
sell your movie
to a uh you know a cable t station
in greece i mean you don't even know the
cable stations in greece let alone how
much they
sold it for and if the contract ever got
negotiated or
done or whatever so unreported revenue
sometimes happens and you know
distributors who watch this are going to
say no we never do that but they do
they do it happens unfortunately
and then there is
what we call the term is called
cross-collateralization
and it is where you're taking either a
pool of films or you're
taking a pool of rights this is where it
gets this is where it gets
this is a concept that will make indie
filmmakers head spin
it's not even complicated but it's just
so let's say you say to the your
distributor
we want you to sell say there's two ways
it happens
three of our films or we're going to
sell one of our films in
15 different territories so let's say
that in the uk
film number one they make a great deal
on it
right but in the ussr
film number two they make a terrible
deal but they spent a lot of money
in you know in traveling there or
whatever so they take
the pr the revenue of one deal and cross
it over
with the cost of another deal so the
costs
neutralize the revenue meaning you get
nothing and they get their cost
paid by your revenue so they're taking a
pool
now they can do that with shared rights
shared films or sometimes they'll do it
with a whole pool of
films that you don't even own it could
be just a whole collection of other
films
and they'll cross everything over and
and
neutralize it all so that they make a
bigger fee
and you get stuck with all the costs
because they don't want to get stuck
with the cost they want all those costs
disseminated through
through the the system and this is where
it gets messy
now i have audited distributors before
like major distributors generally i it's
almost a waste of time to audit the
small guys
the public companies those are the ones
you audit
and it's
messy i mean there are
all kinds of things that i i can tell
you this i i'll tell you one story
so i had a film i'm not going to go into
the details
um i put it out i this one i used
through a distributor
for certain territories i was
self-distributing the film
for for major territories but there are
other territories that i don't deal with
because
they're too complicated language issues
cultural issues i mean i just don't have
the wherewithal to deal with everything
so i gave it to a distributor
they did some decent deals i knew they
did the deals because
i was able on by the internet you can go
on and see where they're playing and
what the schedule is you can you can
verify this stuff you know you can also
phone the just the broadcasters and say
okay when's it playing what's going on
blah blah blah
so i knew the deals had been done and
they also had done
some vod um you know digital deals
and i saw that it was trending really
well
there's some trending reports that you
can look at you can't get the sales but
you can see the trending
all right so i had a pretty good idea
that there were lots of sales
i get the first report back and it's
zero zero revenue
and i said guys this is impossible i
know for a fact
that you sold australia how do you know
because i spoke to the australian
um broadcaster and they told me they
have your movie i'm friends with them
i know for it's impossible that you
don't have revenue let me let's check
they check the system oh you're right
you know what this deal got
um it's called mapping it got mapped
into a different revenue stream it went
to another
i said you guys are public company you
can't i mean mapping errors okay fine
i said there's more there that's not
enough there's so much more going on
they said no there isn't jeff i said
fine i'm gonna audit you
i audited them you have to spend money
you have to get an auditor
you make appointments public company
it's a big deal to do an audit
very expensive but you know
anyway i found two hundred thousand
dollars in missing revenue on the first
audit
the first audit they said and they
danced around well
sorry this that mistake here mistake
there that's a lot of money
that is a lot of missing money it's only
a certain territory
right so um
so then i said okay fine i'm going to do
a so
then another three quarters pass and i
said i'm going to do another audit to
end the year
i go in i find another 50 000 so i say
i believe that there's still some
missing revenue here and here's why i
believe it
and i took them to arbitration because
in my contract i couldn't sue them i had
to
it was built in that was going to be
arbitrated cost me a lot of money to
arbitrate
they spent a ton of money on a big fancy
lawyer
and it went to an arbitrator and it took
six months and
i thought it was going to be a slam dunk
but they out lawyered me
and i'm a lawyer and they outlaw and i
learned a really good lesson about legal
proceedings
and it's got nothing to do with film
reporting or film distribution it's all
about legal manipulation and how to game
the system
and they're a big public company and
they out lawyered me
and i know that i left a lot of money on
the table not to mention how much i
spent on the arbitration
and you asked me before you know is
there any regrets that i have i would
have dealt with that one differently but
you don't know that until after the fact
anyways how many indie film producers
after that i came home after that day
after the final this judgment on the
arbitration i said to my wife
i'm sick to my stomach about this but
i'm way sicker about
how many indie filmmakers have been
screwed by this company
probably for the last decade
thousands thousands of films have
probably lost
hundreds tens of millions of dollars
have been
left on the table because nobody
can afford to do what i did and i lost
i lost that's what goes on that goes on
all the time
and it's a shame and it would be great
if
somehow you know the world could i said
i'm going on a crusade i said to my wife
this is it
i'm going on a crusade i am gonna go and
i'm gonna
dig up everything from every public
company from every filmmaker and i'm
gonna be the hero
and she said just go to sleep you know
tomorrow morning you wake up you'll be a
calmer
you know that crusade would be a
lifetime thing for me and it would cost
10 million dollars in legal fees now if
i could put a fund together
from all the filmmakers you know to
represent them or if
the filmmakers did have representation
then and you know in some type of
protection agency or something like that
who could
represent them that would be fantastic
but they don't
indie filmmakers don't have any
associations like that they don't have
any to go it alone is impossible
it's costly and crazy and you don't know
what you're doing and it's
and it's and it's you can't do it maybe
to go to this group
but you know they don't nobody's got any
money so
but tens of millions of dollars have
been left on the table
hundreds of millions i i can't even
fathom how much just based on my own
experience
how much has been screwed
how how much indie filmmakers have
walked away from
because they don't know and even if they
did know be hard to get it
and with the collateralization of these
films with the distributor
is that similar to cdos that what sunk
the housing market in some sense
the collateralized debt obligations no
no it's not the same
okay so it's it's but but so so they
package
these films and they sell them to these
different territories
and let me give you another example okay
this really really irked me
but again you have to be able to dig
into the weeds
to get this example so another
distributor i was using
is also australia happened to be so they
sold a package
so they're representing many many many
films okay i was one film in a package
of probably say
25 that they sold to a
a broadcaster in in australia i got the
report
my number was like i don't know 75
dollars
for a like five year deal broadcast deal
on
one of my best films it was like some
stupid number
like literally less than a hundred
dollars i phone them up and i say what
what is this
it's a five-year deal and you sold it
for 75
well we did a package deal you were one
of a package
so we had to prorate the numbers i said
pro rate
like how much i'd like to see the pro
rating sorry we don't share that because
it's other privileged information for
other films
so of course i did a little digging only
to find out that you know the
10 main films that were sold they owned
not only the distribute they owned them
they were proprietary
so what they did is they took everybody
else's films pretty well gave them away
for free
in order to get the revenue for their
films
that's a very common practice and
there's nothing you can do about it
i mean there's lots you can do if you
know about it and you can
contract that kind of thing also but
it's super super tricky
and you had a leg up and that you had a
friend
i knew so i knew the deal was there
right so so most people wouldn't be
privy to that information they wouldn't
know
you wouldn't where first of all well you
get reported it was on the report
you know and there was a revenue number
or some stupid number so so at least
they reported something i'm
the other example i gave when is when
they don't report anything so you never
even know that
okay right yeah no there's there's two
types there's they don't report anything
so you can never even question it
because
you never even you don't know what are
you gonna go phone every territory
around the world and do research
every week and say hey i heard you sold
this to that you don't know
this is they reported it but it was so
low at least there's something you can
question
and then it was a package deal and
there's not much you can do if you
hadn't contracted against that because
that's their privilege to do that i mean
they shouldn't
it's wrong but it happens is this the
same type of stuff that's going on in
the music industry
i don't music's not i mean you know i
know music
but i'm i i think music's even worse
music is is just i mean first of all
it's an older industry
and it was a bigger industry for a while
and um
it's just so easy to cheat and pirate
music and
yeah i think it's worse it's it's it's a
real problem with all
intellectual property software anything
like that
anything that's hard to like you know
that it's hard to
it's i guess it's a problem with
anything anybody who does dishonest
business
right i mean you could have hard
products too and inventory and you know
sometimes it disappears and it was
destroyed or returned or this or that i
mean you know it happens all over the
place
sure they call it shrinkage that's
exactly right
that's what it's called shrinkage so
maybe that's what we should call it in
the
film industry but uh there seems to be a
lot of it
so that's part of you know hopefully
knowing what you're doing and paying
attention
but it's it's not easy sure and now a
lot of things can be blamed on computer
error
before maybe human error everything
everything that's that's exactly what's
called a mapping error
mapping means that revenues flow in and
then they get disseminated to each of
the films
that's the map and and they claimed
because i was going to sue them after
arbitration but they claimed
to the arbitrator that the mapping was
wrong and they showed you know
and i said guys it's a real problem that
a public company your size has mapping
errors
can you imagine if we started digging
how many mapping errors i mean like i'm
a little tiny
pebble in an ocean compared to what you
guys do i'm one little tiny independent
film
it's really bad that you got mapping
errors and so many of them
and i just went digging and i found that
and that's like surface stuff
yeah so you know maybe i shouldn't be
accusatory and say
that it happened on purpose but i am
saying that
and you have to pay for an arbitrator
correct oh yeah so you have to go to a
list of
no hold on when you initiate arbitration
not only have to pay for
my side i had to pay for their side
that's the way arbitration works
wow yeah yeah it was
it it was a pride thing and you know
it's just one of those
stubborn i just don't want to get taken
advantage of
but the way the legal system works is
even if you win you lose
you win the battle and lose the war
because you know even if you win the
issue it costs you twice as much to
litigate it
sure so
such is life but the light at the end of
the tunnel is
that movie still was very successful and
i was
happy to have made it and if i focus on
the negatives then
i'll be miserable so i try to focus on
the pauses which is what most people do
um but uh you know it's good to
at least know what you're doing so at
least you have a shot at getting it done
properly
you